caitlin girl let me see that ring
i know oh my gosh i've been staring at
it all day
oh my gosh oh my gosh oh my gosh i'm
like i just keep doing this with
everything i'm like hello
jason bravo mister well done well done
let's go to the very start of this you
just proposed
so walk us through the proposal how did
it all go down mister
yeah so i had it all planned to actually
propose
in cabo because caitlyn hasn't seen her
mother in over a year and a half
so i figured what a perfect time to do
it that was until about a week ago i did
some research and i could have some
custom issues bringing the ring over and
like how brutal would that be
if i get pulled over at customs going to
mexico and they're going through the
ring and she saw it
before it all happened so i made a quick
adjustment and i was thinking you know
like what's important to kaitlyn i knew
that she wanted something
intimate not extravagant and i knew she
wanted something that was meaningful to
her
and i think one thing that's very
meaningful to her is just having
precious moments with the people she
loves so one thing she's done before
is she'll interview on her podcast her
dad
she won't release the podcast but she'll
have that audio recording
uh forever that she can keep and she'll
ask questions about his childhood
and same with her mother and then
caitlin told me about a week ago
she that she wishes so bad she had that
with her grandmother
and so that's when i clicked i'm like
how else can i get this audio forever
and video but still shock her and so i
worked with her manager
and we set her up that she thought she
was doing a podcast with me
we were in the studio we never record
video so her manager said hey there
could be this big opportunity
with someone so we're going to record
caitlyn was excited about it
and so when she said that we're like
this is perfect so caitlyn was
interviewing me
and at the 30 minute mark she went to go
bring on her guests meanwhile i'm like
sweating bullets for that first 30
minutes trying to podcast like
so she the best part is she was supposed
to bring on her guests and that was i
had one thing memorized everything else
i just kind of said from the heart
the one thing that i memorized was
caitlyn there
is no guest well she went to bring on
the guest and i was like
panicking and she's like and i was like
where is the guest
where's the guest cleo where's the gas
and i'm like
caitlyn caitlin then wouldn't tell her
what you said
well so he's like caitlyn caitlin and i
was like what
and then he was holding the microphone
and he said
we're not doing a podcast and i was like
you forgot to hit record didn't you
i thought that's what he meant and he's
like no this this is something else and
he got up and i saw him grab a ring box
from the drawer and i was like oh i was
like oh this is happening right now and
then i was like trying to be so present
but i was so overwhelmed and i was so
embarrassed because i was wearing a
shirt that said tequila for breakfast
and i was like this feels very on brand
but also very inappropriate
and then it worked out perfect where her
family couldn't be here and our family
spread all out and we're gonna go see
your mom but we had all of our family
scheduled to zoom in for five times
and say congratulations we could record
that audio and again we'll have that
forever to show our kids grandkids
such a precious moment you know and so
katelyn how do you feel like he did
oh it was everything i could have asked
for because
i really did think a jason way of doing
it would have been something extravagant
and really big and like i so i actually
thought he was gonna do it maybe in
mexico
on the beach and i would have saw it
coming so i'd be like whoa okay he asked
me to go like
horseback riding on the beach this is
when it's gonna happen like the most
obvious thing
but i yeah i really wanted it to be
intimate and just like in in our home
was perfect i was just i loved that it
was just during our podcast we were
having
such good conversation too and like
jason looked at me at one point and he
was like your energy is unbelievable
right now and i was like i'm just in
such a good mood and i'm just loving
this podcast
and i didn't even know it was happening
so um yeah the words that came
out of his mouth were insanely beautiful
and i was just like
we've never locked eyes like that in our
lives and we were just like holding
hands so intense and i was just trying
to listen to every word and
i still blacked out but i can't wait to
like listen back to it and see it
all play back because it was really
special that's amazing so when are all
your fans going to be able to listen in
on this special moment or will they
because you have been quite the open
book when it comes to your relationship
i don't know i haven't made a decision
yet but i do
i love sharing things with people i need
to i need to watch it back first too
because like you said i was like shaking
and i was just staring at your eyes i
don't even
before we started the podcast remember
you were so
you kept fixing your hair and you were
all nervous about how you were sitting
and i was like dude
you've been on camera before remember
you said that no you had no idea
zero zero zero i wouldn't have been
wearing a tequila t-shirt yeah
that's the best the best part is her
manager was like yeah jason's kind of
dressing up for this like do you like
trying to get like would you want to
change it
you're good jason always dresses up
we're fine i luckily got my nails done
the day before but i would like these
are some funky nails
obviously now you're engaged it's oh my
gosh when y'all gonna have kids how many
kids so
just like when are you gonna get engaged
then when are you gonna get married then
when are you gonna have kids then you
have one when's the next one
are you gonna try for more it's you know
you just gotta expect that
i mean i'm guilty of asking people those
questions for me i'm ready to go full
speed i'm like let's do this yeah
let's go okay papa be ready to get going
let's do it oh it's going to be an
engagement moon baby
it might be caitlyn do you think you're
going to be low-key bride or are you
going to be brazzilla mama
i'm going to be so low-key i i saved it
you better watch out try carefully
that's true
you never know what you're going to get
with me so i'm i don't know why you
signed up for this for life
because it's always like crazy that's
the exciting part
yeah um i honestly don't think i will
because
i've never like i don't know i've never
thought i've never been the little girl
who put the like
pillowcase on her head and thought about
her wedding day and i don't have a
specific way of how it looks i'm just
like
i'm more about the people who are there
but once we get going on it i might
change i don't know you'll have to come
back and ask me later
one thing we talked about last night
actually though there's obviously been a
lot of bachelor weddings and we were
thinking about our wedding parties and
talking about we're like
i don't know that there will be one
person from the
say that because what if there is oh oh
oh
maybe there will be sorry bachelor
nation
no there's there's a couple girls i
think might be in mind okay
now what about artem perhaps is he going
to be teaching you your first
dance as a newly wedded couple that
would be
a really good idea he should teach us a
little waltz or something to do
i could use a lesson or two for myron i
have got to ask you
is the ring neil lane
the ring is not like neil lane wow i
couldn't even say that it was not nearly
a live meal though
yeah it is actually what's cool is it's
a small business it's a canadian jeweler
right outside of the town that caitlin
was born and put so much effort into
like
even taking designs from caitlyn's
dresses on like red carpets to see like
what she likes and
working like lace in because she wears a
lot of lace so on the side
they custom some lace and stuff to make
it like a caitlyn and kind of like an
edgy feel but still like classic and
it was it was so special they were
awesome now jason
why did you not want to propose on the
bachelor
greatest seasons ever because that could
have been a possibility for you there
yeah i just think that for many reasons
no
no no no yeah i think that was like a
recap
on a another chapter of her life right
and that chapter
uh was one that has happened and one
that is closed and
uh new chapters have started and it just
seemed like it would have
uh the timing wasn't right and i said
don't you dare you're right and we were
just kind of you we knew we didn't watch
really caitlyn did you tell him did you
even think about it no i said don't you
dare i don't want
like like he said it was recapping where
obviously at the end of the show i have
two people proposing to me at the end
and then so for him to come in and
propose and that it was it would have
just been weird and i was like just
don't do it
i want it to be very intimate not not on
tv but honey you know we've seen that
from the bachelor so i mean it's just
like
you never know you never know that's
wrong and i love watching it
i would have loved to watch it but i was
like you know what i've been there know
that let's do it private
this is good no are you thinking that
you're going to do your wedding
privately
like have you thought about maybe
televising it i personally wouldn't want
to tell advice
really no i wouldn't would you
i don't only because i love sharing like
i think
so it would be like having you know all
of your friends there
without them actually physically being
there but at the same time
again i just feel like from being on
television in such a setting like that i
feel like you appreciate the privacy a
little more in the intimate
intimate moments
[Music]
of course the next season of the
bachelorette so how are you feeling
caitlin though about
stepping in as a co-host during this
time in the bachelor nation in the
franchise
yeah you know it was so interesting
because
for one thing i didn't really know what
my role was going to be going into it
you know we talked about being a mentor
for katie
and just being there as like some female
women support
who have been in her position who can
guide her and help her when she's really
struggling because i know
all of us who have been in that position
have wished that we had
that kind of support there with us it
was cool to be a part of this season
because i saw a shift in things i really
saw people
um coming together in a different way
that
from when i was a part of the season
when i was the bachelorette it felt like
they were really trying to make a change
it felt like they were open to talking
about change
it felt like they were really wanting to
just evolve and and
it felt different i was a little scared
to be a part of it just because
um you know everything that's going on
and you want to be part of the positive
change
and when i was a bachelorette i think i
struggled a lot and i was a little
nervous about
going back into that but i was really
pleasantly surprised with how everyone
was
and what was happening behind the scenes
and it just
felt like a really overall positive
experience it was fun jason got to be
there for a small part of it
and uh yeah it was it was it was really
um
exciting to be a part of katie's journey
and
be there as a support system to her and
that's just what it felt like but yeah i
mean i expected
i again when the news came out and it
said co-hosting i was like is that what
i'm doing
like what and i was like i don't know
and so
i yeah of course expected some people to
be excited some people to be upset
that's you know that didn't surprise me
and i totally understand
do you feel like it was much needed
change for bachelor nation and for the
show i mean
what it's been going on for 17 seasons
right well
it's i mean it's been 17 seasons of the
bachelorette and like
what 30 of the bachelor and i feel like
one thing that
they didn't do in the past is change
much they you know this
this um format worked for them and the
show worked and it just kept going and
as
the world changes and as people are
being held accountable
the show has to change and evolve with
those times as well
um and so that's why i was pretty
excited to be a part of this season
because i can see them making
changes and being a part of that and
stepping in and
being like a female role in that was was
really exciting
getting to watch kaitlyn and tasha like
their chemistry
is just awesome you can see like their
banter their chemistry
it's so much fun yeah it was it was fun
to see from the sidelines and you all
have lived it
so you know the you know the psyche of
the girls and what's going on in the
house
and i know i if it was like
i felt like i was one of the producers
just because i was like i know what's
happening here
okay you know what's going on behind the
scenes for sure
well thank you guys so much for
everything congratulations i love it
the engagement i love the ring the nails
are great and y'all have
fun in mexico jason fresh up on those
dance skills in mexico i'm going to get
it going here we go
we'll work on that
you